قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي لود اوستن ان
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بالقضاء على
تنظيم الدوله واشار اوستن في تصريحات في
بغداد الى ان هذا هو الهدف الوحيد لبقاء
الولايات المتحده في العراق
منذ بضع سنوات كان تنظيم الدوله يعبر
العراق ويروع السكان ويهدد استقرار
المنطقه كرد على ذلك شكلت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ائتلافا ضم 80 دوله
وهذا الائتلاف رد على طلب الحكومه
العراقيه العمل الى جانبها من اجل القضاء
على هذا العدو الارهابي سنواصل الاستماع
الى شركائنا والعمل الى جانبهم في هذا
الكفاح القوات الامريكيه جاهزه للبقاء في
العراق بناء على دعوه حكومته نحن ملتزمون
بالقضاء على تنظيم الدوله وهذا هو هدفنا
الوحيد من خلال وجودنا هنا اي تهديد او
اعتداء على قواتنا يقود هذه المهمه
ينضم لنا من بغداد مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
ابراهيم اهلا بك وليد اذا حاولنا ان نفهم
ايضا مجمل التصريحات الرسميه من الجانب
العراقي في ظل هذه التصريحات لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي من بغداد
عبد السلام وزير الدفاع الامريكي تحدث في
نقطتين مهمتين في مؤتمر الصحفي اليوم قال
ان القوات الامريكيه التي هي جزء من قوات
التحالف ستبقى في العراق الى اما الطويل
الى ما بعد تنظيم الدوله وهذه نقطه لم
يتحدث اليها او لم يتم التطرق لها من قبل
على الاقل بهذه الدرجه وبهذه الوضوح من
قبل مسؤوله الامريكي رفيع المستوى وقال
ايضا ان اي بقاء ان اي بقاء لقوات امريكيه
والقوات التحالف يجب ان يكون بضمان وحكومه
الحكومه العراقيه لان هذه القوات موجوده
هي موجوده بالاساس بدعوه من الحكومه
العراقيه وبقائها سيكون ايضا بدعوه من
الحكومه العراقيه ويجب على الحكومه
العراقيه ان تعمل على ضمان وسلامه وحمايه
المناطق التي تتواجد فيها او المقرات التي
تتواجد فيها القوات الامريكيه وهي تتواجد
في ثلاث مناطق رئيسيه في بغداد في مطار
بغداد وفي محافظه الانبار غرب العراق
قاعده البغدادي وفي اربيل في قاعده حرير
عدد القوات يقدر على الاقل من خلال
البيانات الرسميه بنحو 2500 جندي امريكي
لكن النقطه الاساسيه رغم ان وزير الدفاع
الامريكي قال ان المهمه التي تطلع بها
القوات الامريكيه هي غير قتاليه لم يتحدث
بصريح العباره فيما اذا كانت القوات التي
ستتواجد بالعراق حتى الى ما بعد تنظيم
الدراسه تكون قوات قتاليه هو قال انها
تقوم بمهمه دفاعيه وانها تدعم
القوات العراقيه في محاربه وضمان هزيمه
تنظيم الدوله لكنها هذه النقطه مساله بقاء
قوات قتاليه امريكيه هي مساله شائكه وتثير
الكثير من الحساسيه لدى الطرف العراقي
رئيس الوزراء العراقي كان قد تحدث قبل
اسابيع وقال ان العراق لا يحتاج الى قوات
قتاليه سواء من التحالف الدولي او من
القوات الامريكيه وقال ان القوات الموجوده
الان بحاجه لاعاده تعريف
نوع المهمه التي ستقوم بها ويتحدث رئيس
الوزراء العراقي يقول ان القوات العراقيه
ما زالت حتى الان بحاجه للدعم سواء في
مجال التدريب او في مجال المشوره او حتى
في مجال تبادل المعلومات الاستخباريه التي
توفرها قوات التحالف الدولي والقوات
الامريكيه هذه هي النقطه الشائكه التي
يتوقف عندها الجميع هل هذه القوات التي
ستبقى كما تحدث وزير الدفاع الامريكي انها
ستكون لبقاء طويل المدى الى ما بعد تنظيم
الدوله مع بعض امان هزيمه تنظيم الدوله
مثل ما قال هل هي قوات قتاليه هو قال ان
القوات التي تتواجد الان تقوم بمحمد
دفاعيه وتقوم بدور غير قتالي لكنه لم
يتحدث اذا كانت هذه القوات قتاليه وكما
قلت هذه نقطه شائكه يتوجب على الطرفين ان
يحددها لضمان استمرار تعاونهم كما قال
رئيس الوزراء العراقي اليوم عندما استقبل
وزير الدفاع قال ان العراق يتطلع الى
شراكه طويله المدى مع الولايات المتحده
ليس عسكريا فقط
لكن في جميع النواحي العسكريه والاقتصاديه
وايضا في الامنيه من بغداد مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد ابراهيم شكرا جزيلا لك على
كل هذه الاضاحات